as a cloud developer one realization you
quickly have is that despite being on
the clown you don't want everything
publicly accessible in this episode of
cloud networking we cover how to protect
your internal endpoints using cloud nap
stay tuned
[Music]
let's say you've got a cloud application
with internal services and you want to
restrict inbound communication while
still allowing outbound one of the
traditional ways to do this would be
through a VPN service that secures
authorizes and handles that connection
for you
which is fine but runs into a large
problem that you're still using public
IPS which leaves you vulnerable to
malicious actors another secure setup
would be something called a bastion host
basically an external endpoint which
allows your clients to SSH from the
public Internet and still keep your apps
from being public facing which again
works but this only deals with one side
of the problem namely inbound
communication but let's say you have a
multi-tiered application set up in the
cloud and you have an update server
on-premise you want to allow your
instances outbound access to the
Internet for updates patching config
management and more without having an
external IP address that way you can
keep your instances entirely internet
facing in a controlled and efficient
manner for this it makes a lot more
sense to set up a network address
translation NAT gateway machine which
routes traffic and lets multiple VMs in
a subnet reached the internet using a
single public IP address now normally
this requires a fair bit of toil
building a high availability and high
bandwidth nat gateway usually requires
reserving static IP addresses creating
compute instance groups as the nat
gateways creating health checks and
monitor their responsiveness and adding
default routes to these instances and
with traditional Nats you'd have a nat
proxy instance between your cloud
instances and their destination this
means a potential choke point in the
path undermining performance throughput
and availability fortunately Google
Cloud NAT is a Software Defined
Networking Sdn solution that avoids
these problems
fully managed offering that lets Google
cloud VM instances without external IP
addresses and private gke clusters
connect to the internet it doesn't
require custom routing and simplifies
and delivers skill because it uses Sdn
instead of being an instance or an
appliance that you have to manage and
better yet outside resources can't
directly access any of the private
instances behind cloud NAT thereby
helping to keep your B PC's isolated and
secure the best part it doesn't use a
proxy instead each of your internal
instances is given a unique set of NAT
IPS and port ranges which are used by
Andromeda Google's network
virtualization stack to perform that
this means no choke points better
scalability performance and availability
cloud NAT scales seamlessly with a
number of instances and the volume of
network traffic and you get as much
bandwidth as instances that do have
external IP addresses let's dive into
how to set up cloud nap here I have two
VM set up in the same vp c and subnet I
want web server to be private so I've
set it up with no external IP address in
order to access it I've set up a second
VM to act as a bastion host which does
have an external IP and allows for
inbound traffic to my web server I've
also set up firewall rules so that I can
only use the bastion host to SSH into
the web server I'm using the local
terminal to SSH into the bastion host to
then SSH into the web server you can see
here I don't have the ability to access
the public internet because when I try
to pull content from example.com it
hangs now let's set up cloud NAT route
egress traffic from the web server to
the Internet using cloud Nats allocation
of IP addresses head to the Google cloud
NAT page and click get started enter a
gateway name choose the VPC network your
instances are in set the region for the
nat gateway which should be the same as
where your instances are
now create a cloud router in the region
and give it a name leave the rest as
default leave the NAT IP addresses to
automatic which is recommended and
automatically allocates IP addresses
based on usage these IPS are used to you
translate the internal addresses of
instances and now click create now going
back to my web server instance I can now
access example.com and see its content
while it still has no external IP
address it's important to note that
cloud NAT doesn't setup inbound NAT so
instances outside your V PC can't
initiate their own new connections to
your cloud instances with NAT but cloud
NAT is a great managed service for
things like fetching periodic updates
from an external server and another
network as you grow your cloud
environment centralizing control and
simplifying your network topology is
going to save you cycles in the long run
stay tuned for the next episode and
remember optimizing your network means
freeing up your
[Music]